You
Hello. Hello. We're live. We're live. Oh my god, they stole my pudding. I can't believe they did this. We have to teach them a lesson.
Oh, what lesson should we teach them, like math? No, I think we should teach them a lesson that involves pain, Neanna, for what they did to you.
Yeah, let's teach them pain. Let's do it. We're going to get some pain tools. What should we get?
I think I have a bat laying around. Let me hold on. Here we go. I got it. What do you got? I have a gun. Should I use that?
I don't think you should use the gun just yet, but if they don't give the pudding over, then maybe we can switch to gun.
Oh, okay, okay. Then I have a frying pan. Yeah. Okay, frying pan works.
I'm going to get all Latina on them. I'm going to show them what real Latina rage is like.
Yep, they're lucky you're only taking out the pan and not the chunk, you know, like. Yeah, they won't know it.
They're themselves lucky. Yeah. Should we slap them?
I think we should slap them. I think we should start beating the crap out of them.
Yeah. No, it's your turn.
I'm bonking. I'm bonking them. You're blocking them. You got to tell them stuff too.
I don't know. What do I say? I don't speak Spanish. You got to spit on them.
I got to spit on them? All right. Hold on. Let me call them up. What's a pendejo?
It means pendejo.
Okay, okay. You pendejo.
Pendejo.
Come on.
That's what you got for stealing my pudding.
I can't believe it. You piece of shit.
Chad's saying, why does the Dom need Dom lessons?
They don't know what they're talking about.
Get it. Dom, get it out.
Dom, stupid, idiot stealing stuff.
Get these cats from the Brady cat.
Look at the tears, bro. They're crying for real.
I see the tears coming out of their eyes. It's very, it's very satisfying.
Yeah.
I like it when they cry.
It's always the best when they cry.
Yeah. Now do we kill them?
I'm kind of tempted. It's like, oh, this is a school.
I don't know how he snuck in guns to school.
I got my ways.
I'm kind of impressed.
Honestly, I know you were something of a gang banger, Niana, but I didn't know you were like that.
Yeah. I'm all of the gang banger.
I have all of the gang banger inside of me.
That's what I did. You know what?
We should play GTA.
We should do that.
And then we should, I should go and show you what it's like to be a real gang banger.
Yeah. And I can join your gang. Are you part of it?
Yeah. I'm part of my gang.
What's your gang name?
It's called Las Pendejas.
Las Pendejas?
Yeah.
We're the real Pendejas.
Yeah. You can be a Pendeja too.
Okay. I'm down.
Yeah. Let's do it.
Okay. Now give me your lunch money.
You know what? I think we should just shake them down and steal their stuff.
Yeah. Okay.
Give us your money.
Give us the money.
You stole her pudding, so we have to buy her more.
So hand it over.
Hand it over.
Hand over that pudding.
Put in these nuts in your mouth.
No. Okay.
Well, we can, I don't have, we can take off their nuts and we can stick them in their mouth.
Oh, that's a lot of stuff. You can do that.
Okay.
Like when he's dead, we can possibly do that. I don't know.
Yeah. I don't know why you would do that when he's dead.
Because it's just ultimate disrespect.
That's what they deserve.
Like teabag him?
Like when you teabag someone after they die?
Yeah. Except I'll be cutting off his balls and sticking them in his mouth.
So.
Okay.
Everything in 4K.
I'm going to be the one on the camera.
Are you going to sell this on the dark web?
Yeah. I'm going to put it on the dark web.
With all of the beheaded videos.
Oh, perfect.
We're going to make so much freaking money after what they did to you.
They don't deserve anything.
You know?
We're going to be rich.
You only have 78 cents in a cat sticker?
Are you poor?
Come on.
I know we don't go to the best school, but what's happening?
Yeah.
We're going to shake him up.
There has to be more stuff in there.
Yeah. What else do you got?
Yeah. What else do you have chat?
What do you have chat?
Tell us what you got.
You're absolutely. You're just broke.
You're just poor. You're useless.
I just.
That pudding was so good.
Thank you.
Get him.
You fucking banejo.
Yeah.
How do you say...
How do you say your mother is a whore?
Your mother is a whore.
Yeah.
This is the learning Spanish street.
Yeah. This isn't it.
This is me learning Spanish.
Yes.
The kidneys, especially the kidneys.
Get the kidneys.
Yeah.
How did you even...
I think we got to interrogate them a little bit.
Yeah.
How did you even know she had that pudding?
She was in the park. How did you haunt her down?
Yeah. How did you haunt me down in the park, bro?
What is a mamabicho?
Is that like...
Mamabicho, that means friendship and magic and homie love.
It's kind of like kiss a homie but less gay.
Oh, okay. That's pretty nice.
I guess. Does that make me a mamabicho?
Yeah. You can be a homie.
Yeah. We're homies.
She's a mamabicho.
Yeah.
Your gang...
Who in the gang sold you out, Niana?
Someone said you were sold out.
Who the fuck did it?
I want some names, okay?
Yeah. We need some names.
Give us some names.
We're like the cartel. If we don't have names, you're getting decapitated.
Yeah. I have a knife.
She has a gun.
We have weapons besides our little blunt objects.
Yeah.
I have a pen and a gun.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna take out...
I think we start threatening with the gun.
Let me get a gun out.
Let me put my pen away.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Oh, what's that?
Okay. The pen stays on.
I got my gun, bro!
I also can't control my own...
There we go.
I'm gonna shoot you, bro!
We got a camera!
That is an eye cat.
It's an eye cat.
It goes like this.
And then mine goes...
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Yeah.
And like this.
Oh, there goes his leg.
Wait, hold on. I need some...
Let me...
There we go.
Emptying a clip in his torso.
Okay.
There goes his other leg.
Now...
Now he's a nugget.
Nugget.
He's a chicken nugget now.
How does that make you feel chicken nugget?
How does it feel being a chicken nugget?
Well, now I'm just dead.
How does it feel, bro?
How does it feel?
That gun's not too big for her.
Be quiet. That's fine.
No! My gun's bigger!
It's bigger than yours, bro.
She can teach you, but she has to charge.
My gun's bigger than yours. I can teach you.
But I have to charge.
Here we go.
I'm over here.
We're stealing your lunch money.
Yeah, we're going to kill you.
Where did I kill them?
Where are my pudding?
Where is the pudding?
Where is my pudding?
What's her pudding?
Where is her fucking pudding?
There's my freaking pudding!
overkill you stole from you stole from her you you have to tone for your fucking
idiocy crimes your crimes yeah and your sins it's in your prison book you sinned
against the bloody cat and the pudding gods mm-hmm it's in your time here they
ate it I need to find a knife we'll cut it out of him and I'll get your
pudding back don't you worry I'm a doctor okay so I can't find a knife but
I have a spoon I'm gonna just pour them like an avocado why is my arm so big
I'm gonna core them like I'm gonna be your height for a second oh nice now I
look small like you and let me put the gun away let me I'm gonna carve into
their skin breaking some bones nice nice nice nice then I'm gonna spoon your
eyes oh sorry you're in the splash zone I'm so sorry okay I don't have my gun
out but I can also shoot them all right I cracked all their bones let me scoop
their guts out let me I'm trying let me let me wait that's what you did I don't
know what noise I wanted to find a wet noise like I'm scooping out their organs
it's cuz it's he's expelling his bowels
okay I plopped their guts open and so I think the pudding should be inside do
you want do you have anything to scoop it out I know I just threw my spoon away so
it's too messy to eat go for it okay where did you find it is it there yeah
I have my pudding and I'm happy where is it I don't see the pudding we got the
yeah but what do we do with them you want I think well I think they might be
already dead oh do we hide the body or let's make sure they're dead for real okay
we're gonna plop them a few times let me get my should I use my bat or my gun use
a gun yeah okay use a gun but okay we gotta confirm the kill confirm the kill
should then 50 times shoot 50 times yeah that's not the gun sound effect oh my god
I'm gonna all right thank you confirming the kill wait hold on where's the
is there what you say
okay they're dead I'm so glad but we gotta well I don't want to get kicked out of school how do
we hide the body let's put them on the grinder the grinder what grinding grinding grinding
like grinding like isn't that in the cafeteria or something yeah it's in the cafeteria and we
can make them into a smoothie here okay let me quick we'll slowly go to the cafeteria
after I find a school cafeteria png
yeah we'll turn them into burger and then we feed it to someone else yeah yeah and that that
that's how we can hide the crime unless you want to eat it uh I'm I don't think I will
you don't want to eat the chat bro she's calling you stinky you know they probably taste terrible I
don't want to eat their gross meat although it's probably really tenderized so maybe I'll take a
little taste after we cook it okay okay we have to cook them up hold on we gotta cook better cook
what yeah wait is this it first time first we eat the pudding then we become the pudding
that's so true in real brother so true we're somehow in the cafeteria we ran over okay um nice
so uh we're here let's do I need a how it's a grinder sound effect
I'll be the grinder
I'm playing blender noises
oh yeah yeah okay blended silly you're blended so hard what does that say in Spanish in the chat
they said okay they said they love bugary blondes
okay uh I got they're all blended up I made them into a drink
so let me pull up the drink
color are they um you be surprised
what color are they they're brown they're brown you want some I put some boba pearls in it so
it helps it go down easier oh um no I try I need to go first all right hold on let me let me
it doesn't taste it I know it tastes fine you want to sip
no I'm good are you sure it's delicious no I don't trust you you're such an imposter gross okay um
um uh well at least they went to good use I'll just put like a bunch of those out in the cafeteria
so that people will drink them and think that it's boba that we catered boba at school all right
they're gross they're disgusting you're disgusting horrible not even worth the effort should have
never tasted that horrible your mother should have aborted you when she had the chance but we did it for her
so
your mother should have swallowed you
like the like the like the whore she was affectionate
we roasted them yeah nice nice why I just swallowed for her so you're good
yeah they were gross how we should just we just continue to like insult them for like a little bit
let me what's up oh I can teach you some Spanish things okay yeah some more insults
so you say mama huevo mama huevo mama huevo what does that mean it means
they suck a pee pee like that mama huevo oh yeah suck that pee pee that's what it means
and then you say bendejo you really know bendejo and then mama michel that's my
fan them and then
and then you can say estupido means they're stupid estupido estupido and you can say cabron
it means like they're a goat but not in the goaded way but they're kind of like a bad goat
and they're they're a bitch yeah okay cabron yeah this is how duelingo looks like now bro yeah
yeah this is where the new where the duelingo vtuber I mean no word that's no we're just
capital is what are you talking about yeah okay and then what else can I show you but they had
four girls but I doubt there's girls in this chat
I'm blessed unless anyone to prove me wrong any ladies in the place with style and grace
put your hands in the air if you would you're player too if I usually have two percent female
watchers yeah to present but I think it's not real it's fake yeah it's probably really fake
they probably it's just like when they when they go to make a character in a video game and they
always just pick a female character they just selected that for youtube see youtube they use
their girls because they always play the girl the female player dingy character yeah I think
I think honestly the two percent is just the two like the people that the girls that I've
collabed with before yeah that like cuz I know like I have I have I model the vtubers that I come
through so I guess they're otherwise there's nobody in a I think they're hiding if they're here
yeah definitely 100% but uh anyways my Tommy Hort's now from drinking that that was disgusting
um really gross I might throw up I can't believe
no maybe I don't know my tummy is rumbling right now for real actually
I drink for the sound effect like I don't know what I drink on my desk but it's been
I know that you have our days in there
my tummy is rumbling your tummy and the skews of zero seven for your tummy hold on let me is there
a hold on let's do some tummy sound effects
you know one time I went in a VR world with another vtuber called meat and she took me to
a war world a war world and it was so weird yeah she took me there and there was this thing and
it was growling on its tummy and then he like grabbed you and then he ate you and it all happened
on stream so like the chat got the whole point of view of them being eaten and then we were in
the stomach and it was all gooey in there and there was green inside and then he was still rumbling
on the tummy here it was an experience yeah it was so weird bro I didn't even know that existed
in VR chat yeah she knows the curse worlds she took me to a lot of them oh well I have to ask
me to do the same for me I don't even I need to get like like a VR chat avatar shit oh my god
that'd be fun do you have VR chat I do I do have VR chat
yeah we can do it we can do it I've never I've only used it once so I don't know how to how to
use it oh I can teach you okay that'll be that'll be the next collab uh unless the the gta server
comes first oh that has to come first yeah and I'm so hyped bro I know I'm so excited can't
wait to can't wait to hop on yeah and we'll play to my heart's content with all the girls in there
bro there's like 20 girls in there already oh it's about to be popping let's go yeah hey yeah um but I
don't know why we're telling this dead body that because they're useless but you know it's whatever
but oh yeah he's in his he's in your tummy now he has become one with you I'm playing tummy
growl noises yeah no it's like oh she no co what I never watched oh she no co what what happened
does somebody get bored and oh she no co no but the baby comes out and it's reincarnation so the
chat's in there now you're pregnant pregnant wait so in oh she no co there's a scene where the
reincarnated person is just in the womb yeah what am I going to have to do like a pregante
role play one of my gen mates did that bro I have a friend she did a role playing pregante stream
and so she did like birthing ASMR birthing isn't that just her screaming
yeah that's what it was that's what it was and she had like doctor noises
I'll be the doctor okay actually that would be kind of funny giving births a chat
yeah and we gotta we gotta make them like ugly
honestly uh all my tomagachi kids because I like I have my tomagachi uni and I say that you know
chats the father but all the kids are ugly so I just let them die
no you're gonna do that to chat you're gonna birth them and then they're ugly so then we kill them
that sounds like a good idea we put them out of their their misery
let's do it they would never survive in the world otherwise it's just being so ugly
we got cute because they ugly bro
I should three point shoot it into the into the garbage like if it's a basketball
oh
does he eat the fetus fetus the lettuce eatus the fetus into the trash yeah poor chat um so yeah
that was the role play guys uh neanna did you want to introduce yourself hi my name is
i'm a bridey gremlin cat I stream on youtube and on the twitch yes yes yes yes her uh twitter is in
my as pinned in my chat and I also have her links in my description so make sure you go check her out
uh neanna has been a dear friend of mine for quite some time and it's nice to hang out with her again
I missed her luck
nice to see you um but yeah we'll probably do some uh gta content at some point and um yeah it's
gonna be chaotic I want to chill chat my three arms I know wait can I show my chat my do I have
can I have a third arm yeah we're spiders oh my tummy won't stop growling oh my god
yeah I'm my I'm my puke later I already puked this morning
I like drink so much lemonade the acid just made me
oh my god you're ready for that birthday ASMR
it's it's morning sickness because I'm pregnant with chat
oh my god I don't know it might have been the takeout I had I had seafood and I
I've been just like hitting and missing with seafood yeah bro I I had takeout from a bar
because they're the only thing open at 12 a.m so that's the only thing I have because I'm a v-tour
and I stopped streaming late and then this it's a hit and miss with those foods yeah no no no no
that stinks yeah like I've already like peeped like three times because I've gone takeout and it
made me sick yeah bro takeout hate takeout hate we we cook like traditional wives oh yeah everybody
knows v-tours they're like traditional wives yeah yeah we're tried wives five course meals
they do that yeah look can you cook no
I think I recall us feeling at the very distant past you being on stream cooking something or
like we're in a call and I swear you burnt something like I literally almost set fire to
my house like two times already and then everything is if it's not overburnt and like setting fire to
the place then it's raw yeah she likes it she likes it burnt there's no in between either it's raw
like Gordon Ramsay says it's raw like that or it's literally on the fire can I make you a
pudding sandwich hold on I'm gonna put some puddings around you no puddings no puddings oh it's so jiggly
no no no no no it's behind you but people get the idea
doesn't Neanna look so cute with her little outfit this is my pudding throne I'm a pudding queen
no wait wait Neanna show them your special talent that we figured out when you press the button
she sucks them in she could she could smack someone be like pull out your gun and say you're under
abreast you're under abreast I'm gonna shoot she's like a fembot from Austin Powers just shooting
with her boobs oh my god how do I make it go back I don't know my own boobs scared me
wait you're like medium-sized yeah premium I don't know
you're trapped you're trapped I'm trapped in the medium it's fine she hit puberty hit her like a truck
like truck yeah truck couldn't hit my titties yeah um but hi if you are if you're coming from
Neanna's channel hi my name is Sheebie Cottonbum I'm usually a bunny um but I'm a cracker all
the day and I'm your favorite girl failure Dom of Vealer we're just a bunch of goofs over here
yeah she's a Dom that's it I think uh Neanna has kind of a Dom street corner though she's she's
very yeah she's very small Dom you know she'd like probably like step on you and stomp on you
yeah I'm like a chihuahua um I mean I'm like yeah no no no no no don't air quote Dom at me
don't air quote now you know I'll push you guys into her place don't even get me get twisted
don't get on to me stun but everybody wants you to join Vealer
the chat though they're like strotties like guys she's no that's they're warm here
okay Neanna Neanna's her own stream her own person I imagine because of my shower stream
they're like we need more that was an accident I flashed the chat accident in the
oh my god um but I don't yeah no I don't think I would want to hear cursed
audios coming from Neanna I just wait what do you mean by that uh
oh the saucy yeah the saucy I'm not very don't worry gen four is actually never a thing it's
never going to happen that's the that's the inside joke um don't worry don't worry you're safe
you're safe uh well we got your pudding back so we do you want to keep that swing or you want
to you want to end it here I think you should check on that tummy and see if my tummy is like
this entire time I've been tempted to pull the mic down so you guys can hear it oh I want to hear
it wait hold here's the baby you want to hear anything
it's not sensitive like my 3dio hold on I'll switch to my 3dio
and then people will hear my stomach uh but I don't think you'll be able to hear it unless
you listen on the stream oh yeah what I knocked over the gross drink on my desk it's fine
she is huge she's big I'm I'm big why am I so big okay why am I so big quick if you're intimidated
get stepped on hold on get stepped I don't have any legs never mind
all right let me see no feet for free bro okay for that oh I'm switching on my 3dio
okay no feet for free no yeah huge don't you don't you don't you don't you don't you don't
yes he is my big sis yes yes big sis the biggest sister do you guys like the tummy noises can you
hear even hear them I can't but maybe chat can yeah I need I need like give me something chat
you cannot chat this is real
hello
this is real it's kicking
oh pochita says I hear it slightly
turn up turn that for bop bb bb bb bop this is very small it's screaming
a little bit
oh you should up your game on bs or something like a filter add again yeah
yeah
um
tamagotchi child it's like it's not doing it now it's shy
it's a shy little guy it's a chat oh my cat food is supposed to go
I'm like I heard that
I'm back all right I'm gonna end it here and go feed my cat
this was supposed to be like a meme ASMR it was supposed to be silly not like a real ASMR
I might stream afterwards play some Elden Ring uh Neon are you streaming afterwards
she she she's going to bed she's thinking about it yeah all right bye guys
oh you gotta tell them that they're stinky that's what I do every stream
oh yeah you're stinky yeah you stink how do you say it in Spanish you stink
how do you say they have stinky nuts
mmm
yeah
you